it's nice to meet you mr girl
nice to meet you too
i'm just kidding
i don't have an accent i'm just messing
with you welcome back fresh fam it is
nas prize and on today's episode we're
taking a look at some of the biggest
movie and tv milestones that paved the
way for asian american representation on
screen the works showcased here aren't
just well-crafted pieces of filmmaking
they are beacons of the asian american
experience driving cinematic character
and story in front of and behind the
camera so follow us as we dive into some
of the major studio releases television
and even casting and filmmaker choices
that have broken representational ground
for the asian american audience and as
always potential spoilers lie ahead for
the films on this list so watch at your
own risk
the karate kid
you promise learn
i say you do
no question
that's your part
dear
still very few martial arts franchises
can say that they've started and
continued a legacy quite like the karate
kid with the production of three sequels
a remake a television series and even
some video games and a short-lived
animated series across nearly four
decades it's kind of difficult to argue
against the franchise's immense impact
on pop culture but it's even more
difficult to argue that it would be
anywhere near as big as it is without a
certain japanese maintenance man world
war ii veteran karate master of infinite
wisdom mr miyagi asian american actor
pat morita based his portrayal of mr
miyagi on fumio damora a japanese
martial arts master born in yokohama
japan who actually worked on the stunts
for the film wash all the car
then relax
remember dear
no question
pat shaped mr miyagi's mannerisms speech
and accent from damora in fact morita
was born in isleton california to
japanese immigrants so he naturally
spoke in an american accent one of the
things that maria could not always mimic
though the stunts so damora served as
marita stunt double on the film as well
according to marina he was credited as
noriyuki pat morita because they wanted
to promote his japanese heritage not
only did the film elevate maria as mr
miyagi to pop culture legend status it
earned him a best supporting actor
nomination at the 1984 academy awards it
is also said that the karate kid
directly popularized karate in america
on a mainstream level unlike any other
work before it wax on
wax off
breathe in through nose
out the mouth
wax on
wax off
don't forget to breathe very important
wax on
wax off
the joy luck club
the next week i brought rich to mom's
birthday dinner sort of a surprise
present i figured she was going to have
to accept rich like it or not
oh [ __ ] this is my father how are you
doing happy birthday
i'm good and ma this is rich
great to meet you in 2020 the joy luck
club was added to the library of
congress as being culturally
historically or aesthetically
significant and not just for its
popularizing of mahjong it was the first
major modern hollywood picture featuring
an all-asian and predominantly female
cast also notable was the screenplay
which was co-written by amy tan the
author of the novel on which the film is
based in 1993 this wasn't just cracking
a glass ceiling this was smashing it so
many spots on his face
of course the night was still young
thank god i already prepped him on the
emily post of chinese manners
actually
there were a few things i forgot to
mention
uh let me make a toast you shouldn't
have had that second glass according to
producer janet yang director wayne wang
lost his temper at a marketing meeting
when presented with the poster options
for the movie none of the options
featured images of the actresses faces
but rather abstract images of wood
cutouts and pictures of the character's
backs here is an additional fun fact two
of the actresses had roles in mulan with
ming na wen voicing the title character
in the animated film and rosalind chao
playing mulan's mother in the live
action 2020 version this dish not salty
enough no flavor
it's too bad to eat but
please
that was our cue to eat some
and proclaim it the best she'd ever made
you know linda
all this needs is a little soy sauce
the wedding banquet
film 1993's the wedding banquet raked in
23.6 million dollars in the box office
from just a million dollar budget when
you do the math it was the most
financially profitable movie that year
even topping jurassic park keep in mind
jurassic park was the highest grossing
film of 1993 making 914 million dollars
worldwide on a 60 million dollar budget
not only was the film a rare
co-production between taiwan and the
united states it was also a rare gay
asian american story
obama
foreign
the wedding banquet focuses on a gay
landlord who convinces a young female
tenant to enter a marriage of
convenience in order to please his
traditionally minded parents it was
lauded for its open and humorous take on
the especially heavy taboo asian subject
of sexuality star winston chao was
discovered by lee while working as an
airline steward and had to be sweet
talked into entering the production
specifically lee had to promise chow on
set acting lessons with his own
designated acting coach chow has since
gone on to build a successful career in
film playing various emperors kings and
on five different occasions chinese
statesman sun yet sen which can all be
traced back to those free acting lessons
provided by ang lee
yogurt
[Music]
better look tomorrow
whose party is this
so it works
man you don't need invitation just hear
everybody and you go they're all [ __ ]
drunk anyway before he got famous for
his additions to a certain fast car
franchise director justin lin got on the
radar for better luck tomorrow a drama
about an overachieving group of teens
who enter the world of small-time
criminal enterprises according to actor
sung kang who plays han in the film
lin's original investors wanted the
entire cast to be caucasian one producer
even offered lin a million dollars on
the condition that actor mikuli kolken
star is the main character thankfully
lin turned it down and proceeded to fund
the film with his own credit cards
speaking of han fans of the fast and
furious universe will get a kick out of
this fact better look tomorrow is
actually the first time the character of
han makes an appearance retroactively
making the film a part of the fast
continuity though it's not considered an
installment in the franchise
what's up boys uh i think if bible stays
next door right
oh [ __ ] no look at this
it's a chinese
the film is noted for portraying asian
american upper middle class kids as
being fully susceptible to the same
urban gangster mentality that some early
2000s suburban teenagers went through
and not just encased in passive asian
stereotypes at a q a during sundance a
reporter asked if lin was being
irresponsible for portraying asian
americans in a negative light critic
roger ebert stood up and shouted that
asian americans can make whatever films
they want about whoever they want and do
not have any obligations to represent
their people the point being no one asks
martin scorsese if he feels responsible
for showing italians as criminals
harold and kumar go to white castle
[Applause]
dude what is that is that a pterodactyl
i do not know what that is
2004's harold and kumar go to white
castle is a notable blockbuster for many
reasons not the least because it was the
first stoner blockbuster to star two
asian american actors as its leads jon
cho and kal penn only further adding to
the shattering of asian american
stereotypes the characters of harold and
kumar are just regular middle class
americans period the film represents one
of the first times in a comedy that
being asian wasn't the butt of a joke or
played for comic relief the gags
centered around martial arts heavy
accents or sexless nerds that had become
staples in earlier comedies are nowhere
to be found here
why don't you leave that guy alone and
go to some snowboarding videos or
something
[Music]
i didn't mean you should do something
about it
[Music]
harold and kumar curse do drugs and hate
work they're entirely relatable in fact
race has no bearing on the plot of the
film at all as one critic said at the
time the movie didn't target asian
american audiences first it was just a
hilarious stoner journey about the love
of white castle burgers and these two
very appealing human characters
did dooky hazard just steal my [ __ ]
car
yes
i think you did
ah
the walking dead
stephen young's portrayal of glenn on
the walking dead might be the most
significant asian-american character in
us tv history and that's because amc and
robert kirkman truly made glenn the
heart of the show putting him in 66
episodes the eighth largest character on
the show while clocking the most
on-screen walker kills in the series
glenn didn't actually murder another
human being until season six but yun
apparently begged producers to let glenn
waste some guys after seven seasons
being the token nice guy
nice moves there clint eastwood
using a sheriff
come riding in to clean up the town
wasn't my intention yeah whatever yeehaw
you're still a dumb
the actor told new york magazine to be
quite honest as an asian person
sometimes accessing your own humanity
when you're outside in the world isn't
easy because you're usually just
shrunken down to your label fans felt
otherwise they overwhelmingly point to
glenn's grisly murder as the moment that
their opinion changed about the walking
dead fans and critics almost unanimously
came to a consensus of too much negan
that was gross and now i don't want to
ever watch my favorite tv show again
thanks
right side
it'll be the fall that kills us i'm a
glass that full kind of guy
you the one barricaded at the alley
somebody did i guess when the city got
overrun whoever did it was sinking not
many geeks get through
back at the tank why'd you stick your
neck out for me
call it foolish naive hope that if i'm
ever that far up creek somebody might do
the same for me
i guess i'm even bigger dumbest than you
[Music]
to be 2k
george is the love of my life
i'm proud of him i've heard that people
[Laughter]
he's wonderful
well if you see him talking to me
sometimes you wouldn't think so
if you haven't seen the documentary
about og star trekker and living legend
george takei then now is better than
never the doc not only covers his legacy
around trek and being one of the most
celebrated openly gay asian american
stars ever but it also details the
immense pain of him and his family
living in two american internment camps
during world war ii oh i miss wren yeah
and i see these dogs
would you like to have a pet we would
love to have them we had the papillon
dog we're gay we're gay men
of course we'd love to have pets in 2012
takei was able to share these
experiences when he starred in a
broadway musical adapted from his
memoirs about his childhood called
allegiance between 1966 and 1968 takei
was in 52 episodes of the only tv show
on the air at that time making him the
first asian american star of a hip
program today takei continues to be one
of the most active proponents for lgbt
rights and as such is one of the most
famous people on the internet amassing
over 10 million facebook followers
usually when we're talking to
journalists this segues into the
question well you once had a dog would
you why don't you have children
taking on a child
where
same-sex relationships were
anathema
wouldn't be fair to the child i don't i
don't agree with you i mean in the uk
environment that you're you've all your
life you've been a pioneer and a a
trailblazer for civil liberties for
people it would have been great for you
to be a model for no but it was
inconceivable if i came out back then
where do you think my career would be
where it is now i have no idea
fresh off the boat
in 2015 fresh off the boat debuted on
abc based on the life of restauranter
eddie huang it was the first u.s network
television show to center around an
asian family since margaret chose
all-american girl back in 1994. by the
end of season one fresh off the boat had
lasted longer than both all-american
girl and the five-episode run of mr t
and tina which starred the karate kids
pap morita and by the end of season
three it lasted longer than another
predominantly asian sitcom airing during
the same time ken zhong's doctor ken
which only lasted two seasons
wait who was on the phone
fresh off the boat was a hit and we
watched 116 episodes of the taiwanese
american huang's as they navigated their
way through the steakhouse business in
orlando florida during the 90s you might
recognize to the actors if you're dc or
marvel fans because randall park played
agent jimmy wu in ant-man and the wasp
and one division as well as dr steven
shin in aquaman and ian chen played
eugene choi in shazam
well kanye heights i want nakayoshia
[Music]
the big sick
do you know how difficult it is to get
an appointment with her she's in very
high demand okay so so can we please
talk about this another time no no kumi
we will talk about this now we have
sacrificed everything for you i know
okay
we have left our family we have left our
home i have missed the birth of my
sister's daughter
i have not seen my mother for 15 years
with a budget of 5 million dollars 2017
is the big sick based on the true story
of writer and star kumail nanjiani's
real life romance with his wife emily v
gordon made 56 million dollars at the
box office becoming one of the top
grossing indie films that year the film
was a semi-autobiographical retelling of
non-gianni and gordon's relationship
which was complicated when the two broke
up and gordon fell into a medically
induced coma luckily both gordon and the
relationship recovered and the big sick
was released on the couple's 10th
anniversary
if you don't want to be a lawyer fine if
you want to do the stand-up comedy and
embarrass us as a family
fine there is only one thing that we
have ever asked for you kumi that you be
a good muslim and you marry a pakistani
girl that is it one thing
can i ask you something something that
has never made sense to me why did you
bring me here if you wanted me to not
have an american life we come here but
we pretend like we're still back there
that's so stupid don't you talk to your
mother like that you don't care what i
think you just want me to follow the
rules but
the rules don't make sense to me
the film earned pretty much universal
acclaim and was the only non-best
picture nominee that year to be
nominated for best screenplay which was
a collaboration between nanjiani and
gordon nanjiani personally reached out
to indian actor anu pamkur to play his
father and convinced him to take the
role by telling him that his actual dad
wanted him for the part i really
appreciate everything you've done for me
i truly truly truly do i really do
and i know islam has been really good
for you and it has made you good people
but i don't know what i believe
i just need to figure it out on my own
you're not myself
you're being selfish you're not thinking
about us
you're not thinking about khadijah in
fact you are not even thinking about
that girl you are in love with
you think american dream is doing just
about whatever you want and not thinking
about other people you're wrong
you are wrong
crazy rich asians
no no i studied in the states too yeah
cal state fullerton
i majored in thought don't stand on
selling money later this is simple food
netflix originally tried to purchase
crazy rich asians for a much bigger
budget but kevin kwan turned it down for
warner's most modest 30 million dollars
to send a message that asian american
films were viable at the us box office
and boy was he right by october 2018
crazy rich asians made over
235 million dollars worldwide making it
the highest grossing romantic comedy in
a decade so lisa what do you do america
um
i'm an economics professor
oh
very impressive econ professor eh wow
you must be very smart good for you
let me get this straight you both went
to the same school
yet someone came back with a degree
that's useful and the other one came
back as asian ellen
constance wu was the only actress
considered for the role of the lead
character while henry golding a former
travel tv host turned down multiple
auditions until director john m chu
reached out to him personally on
facebook meanwhile two of the actors
from crazy rich asians share a
connection to the mcu gemma chan played
minerva and captain marvel and michelle
yeo played elita and guardians of the
galaxy vol 2. colin and erimanta's
wedding is like singapore's event of the
century the youngs are like royalty
did you not know does she not know what
you've never seen before
tell tell what they like
i don't really know what they're i mean
haven't met them yet i'm gonna meet them
tonight i'm going to nick's grandma's
house
you're going to nick's grandma's house
wearing this wearing that
[Laughter]
i thought was a lucky color right yeah
[Music]
about a grandmother who doesn't realize
she has terminal cancer because her
family hides the diagnosis from her and
instead stages a fake wedding for her to
attend is based on the writer director's
own life wang's grandmother was still
alive when the film came out and she
eventually learned the truth about her
condition when it was retitled as don't
tell her for the chinese market and she
realized she was the her at the center
of the film
[Music]
the story was originally shared as part
of this american life segment after
producers in both the us and china
turned down the pitch after it aired
producers began reaching out and finally
wang's great aunt little ninai was hired
to play herself despite initial
hesitation that it was too traumatic for
her to relive lying to her sister about
her cancer diagnosis not only did she
steal the show but she even got to bring
her real-life dog ellen into costar in
her scenes
young man
sherman
[Music]
[Music]
a critically acclaimed hit two of its
actors broke academy award history in
2021. steven yan became the first asian
american and the first actor of east
asian descent to be nominated for the
best actor academy award while his
co-star yah jung yoon who plays his
mother-in-law was the first korean
actress in the academy's 93-year history
to win for best supporting actress the
gentle immigrant story about a
korean-american family making it in the
midwest is also the second korean
language film to be nominated for best
picture coming after 2020's winner
parasite along with nomad lands chloe
zhao minati director lee isaac chung's
oscar nomination marks the first time
the academy has recognized two asian
filmmakers for best director
[Music]
for a movie with such epic firsts it was
actually a very short production filming
took only 25 days with all the scenes at
the creek taking only one day to shoo
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
well friends that is our list of the
most essential asian american milestone
movies after having done this list and
seeing how cinema continues to grow and
evolve it's exciting to know that
there's so much more interesting new and
personal stories yet to be told and
we'll be here to help continue marking
incredible achievements like these so
stick around for more of our
recommendations and we'll see you at the
next one
[Music]